there's a scene in a Christmas carol
we're a couple charity workers visit
Scrooge's office looking for donations
of course Scrooge got a Scrooge so he
kicks them to the curb Havanese are with
all money in the world can't spare a
dime that should feel counterintuitive
to us but has the audience we nod our
heads and think that makes sense
Dickens didn't invent the trope of the
cruel greedy rich guy but he sure
popularized it and there have been
countless example since Montgomery burns
mr. Potter Gordon Gekko Smaug the dragon
the Lannisters the idea that one's
wealth is inversely proportional to
their empathy is a staple efficient but
is there a basis in reality for it does
having more money make you meaner and if
so what can be done about it
[Music]
if I asked you why don't you give away
more money to worthy causes what would
you say I guess we'd all have a response
among the lines of I don't have enough
money that sounds reasonable on its face
but what if I told you that research
suggests having more money makes you
less generous a study by The Chronicle
of philanthropy found that households
burning fifty to seventy thousand
dollars gave 7.6 percent on their
discretionary spending to charity those
earning a hundred thousand gave 4.2
percent and those who made over two
hundred thousand dollars and live in a
zip code where forty percent of their
neighbors earned the same gave only 2.3
percent to charity and the University of
Notre Dame survey found that Americans
below the poverty line were twice as
likely to give up to one percent of
their entire income to charity compared
to those above the poverty line
researchers at UC Berkeley conducted an
experiment where subjects were asked to
rank themselves on a socio-economic
scale from low to high then they were
given some cash and asked how much of it
they considered giving to a stranger
again people who identified themselves
as lower-class
gave away 44 percent more on average
than their higher ranked counterparts
perhaps you've heard about the famous
giving pledge campaign initiated by
Warren Buffett Bill Gates and other
billionaires in an inspiring move they
are trying to convince other super
wealthy families to give away of their
fortune over their lifetime but sadly
out of the hundreds of thousands of
ultra high-net-worth individuals in the
world only a hundred eighty-seven have
signed the pledge in the eight years
since the campaign started there's no
denying there's a self preservation
streak when it comes to amassing wealth
money doesn't just make us more
possessive it can also lead to obnoxious
arrogant social behavior take one study
that washed hundred random partners play
a rigged game of Monopoly one of the two
players started with double the starting
cash collected twice as much when they
passed ago and rolled more dice these
advantaged players demonstrated more
visible displays of Victorious 'no Slyke
dominant physical gesturing and loudly
moving their pieces around the board
they even ate more pretzels that were
specifically located nearer to the
disadvantaged player when asked
afterwards what factors led to their
success many of them pointed to some
sort of inherent skill rather than the
obvious fact that the game was heavily
tilted in their favor from the start
it's like their brains had to find some
sort of self affirming justification for
unearned privilege even pretend wealth
can turn nice aunt Sharon into a
cutthroat real estate Barry what's going
on here what is it about wealth that can
turn even the best of us into an
uncaring Scrooge one of the major
factors is the connection between wealth
and power the greater your wealth the
more advantages you have in life and the
more power you have over situations
circumstances and people that boost in
our sense of power holds a key to this
phenomenon in a study at McMaster
University subjects were split into two
groups one prime to feel powerful by
recounting a situation where they were
in charge and one was not those feeling
more powerful were far less likely to
exhibit what neuroscientists call
mirroring our subconscious copying of
others behaviors and moods
laughing when others laugh feeling
tension in the room when someone says
something inappropriate getting choked
up watching someone else cry mirroring
is a vital skill that allows us to adapt
appropriately to people around us and
fit into social situations and it is an
essential building block to allow us to
feel empathy if you're wealthy or hope
to be one day by watching $0.02 videos
this might be a bit alarming but fear
not now that you are aware of some of
the dangers that come along with wealth
there are steps you can take to build
empathy and remain generous no matter
how much money you have for starters
don't isolate yourself or surround
yourself only with your wealthy friends
wealthy individuals usually live
physically further apart from others and
when they socialize it's with people at
their same income level but studies show
that wealthy people that live in
economically diverse neighborhoods give
away twice as much to charity than those
that don't
so where you live makes a big difference
and the same guys who did the monopoly
study also found that experiencing
nature can make us more generous the
feeling of awe when we look up at the
stars or over a vast expansive landscape
makes you feel less important therefore
more likely to help someone else out so
take a hike up a teaser well isn't evil
or good it's a tool that can impact the
world in ways beneficial and terrible as
you journey toward a more prosperous
future don't forget to protect yourself
from the emotionally numbing effects of
wealth for example you can set a
specific percentage of your income to
give away no matter how much you make
and try to actively seek out situations
that will connect you with people that
aren't like you it'll help make sure you
own your money and it doesn't own you
and that's our two cents if you give to
charity how do you decide how much and
how do you stick to it let us know in
the comments
you
[Music]